he's barely in the original trilogy but
Bounty Hunter Boba Fett is still one of
the Star Wars saga's most iconic
characters from his unusual Origins his
presumed death and beyond his Disney
plus Revival there's enough Boba Fett
lore out there to fill a salac pit let's
dive in before boba's story can be told
we have to go back to events that
predate his first chronological onscreen
appearance over a decade before the
Clone Wars Jedi Master ccio di foresees
a terrible Darkness slowly spreading
across the Galaxy despite his attempts
to warn the Jedi Council he is ignored
and removed from his place in the order
after that rejection he strikes to deal
with the cloners on the sea planet of
Cino to create a Grand Army of the
Republic after seeing thousands of star
systems join the separatists the
premonitions of Galactic conflict alarm
The Comedians so the cloners anxiously
agreed to use a Mandalorian Bounty
Hunter D Jango Fett as a genetic
template the Sith get wind of his plans
so they decide to create the perfect
storm to Grant themselves control over
the Clone Army in exchange for for his
genetic template D Jango Fett negotiates
for a single and altered clone a
genetically pure boy designated Alpha
whom he would keep for himself living on
Camino Jango raises Alpha as if he were
his own son renaming him Boba so as to
separate him further from his clone
Brethren and like the Clones who are
trained from their youth to become
obedient soldiers Boba is taught to
think independently and learns the
basics of bounty hunting from his father
most fans saw booba Fett in 1980s The
Empire Strikes Back but thanks to attack
of the Clones and the Clone Wars he's
been given a pretty in-depth history
that extends far beyond his bounty
hunting profession prior to the start of
the Clone Wars Jango Fett is hired to
assassinate Senator Padme amadala the
eventual wife of one Anakin Skywalker in
the Clone Wars Jango is described by the
Mandalorian prime minister in less than
flattering terms insinuating that fed
may not actually be Mandalorian himself
when the Clone Wars came out in 2008 the
story wents that Jango Fett was indeed
Mandalorian but the planet's officials
were desperate to hide it but in 14 when
Disney announced that the Star Wars
expanded universe was no longer
considered Cannon D Jango lost his
original backstory even though the Clone
Wars remain thankfully the Disney plus
series The Mandalorian set the record
straight once and for all in chapter 14
the tragedy an aged Boba Fett reveals a
chain code of his armor which reveals
that Jango fet was once a Mandalorian
foundling after all your father was a
foundling yes following an attempt made
on Padme amala's life Obi-Wan Kenobi
ends up on Camino where he meets Jango
fet before long D Jango and Boba are in
the process of making their escape and a
fight breaks out between Obi-Wan and D
Jango outside the slave one the feds
Escape but not before Obi-Wan is able to
secure a homing device to the hull of
their ship he catches up to the pair
outside Geonosis and the battle
continues in an asteroid field thinking
they've out run Obi-Wan the fets take
refuge on the planet along with Kuku and
a separatist Army the entire sequence
serves two purposes it demonstrates just
what the FED Starship can do in combat
and it sets AB Boba to be his father's
replacement in the universe not only can
he handle a ship's controls but he's
also pretty bloodthirsty especially when
it comes to the Jedi when the Jedi sawg
andos sister come to Obi-Wan's Aid a
battle ensues that brings them face to
face with the full force of Count
Dooku's Army bobu Fett watches from the
sidelines as his father enters the fry
acting first as Dooku's personal
bodyguard and eventually going headon
against Jedi Master Mace Windu and an
unruly reek after a not so impressive
fight with takes Django out with a
single swing of his lightsaber
separating his head from his body and
leaving Boba with nothing left of his
father except a helmet that should
probably get a good cleaning Boba vows
Vengeance on mace window for his
father's death and disappears into the
vastness of the Star Wars Universe just
as the new Grand Army of the Republic
swoops in to save the Jedi and Usher in
an allout War it's during this time that
Boba Fett meets up with several
Intergalactic bounty hunters the most
notable of these dangerous characters is
Ora sing a former acquaintance of Jango
Ora essentially adopts Boba allowing him
to work on her crew while teaching him
the ins and outs of the trade in the
Clone Wars boba's real introduction to
his father's line of work is rough and
this made all the more difficult by
aura's heartless approach to business
anyone who crosses her is killed without
a second thought and although Boba sees
himself as part of her in a circle it
eventually becomes clear that all he is
to her is a means of advancing her own
personal interest when he's no longer of
any use to her Ora turns on Boba the
same way she's turned on countless
others in her past but before all that
she does offer Boba help in one very
specific regard part of boba fet's
arrangement with Ora Singh involves a
Revenge plot on M Windu in an effort to
avenge his father's death having held on
to his anger toward the Jedi since
attack of the Clones the young fat is
anxious to finally put his plan into
motion boba's first attempt at M Windu's
life involves a bounty hunter posing as
a clone Cadet to gain entrance to the
endurance over a public Cruiser that
houses the Jedi Master he's been
searching for Boba plants an explosive
device in Windows quarters but the
assassination attempt fails when an
unlucky Clone Trooper trips the device
Instead at this point Boba decides the
best course of action is to take out the
ship's reactor Escape alongside a group
of Clone Cadets and then completely
abandon them in the middle of space the
second Aura shows up to rescue him solid
plan even if it is dangerously cruel but
Boba finds himself getting attached to
his fellow cloned siblings making it
difficult for him to sabotage his family
while the idea of leaving his new
friends to die takes a minute to accept
he ultimately does the Bounty Hunter
life is a hard one and it doesn't allow
room for Such trivial things as friends
not willing to just let things go after
his first failed attempt boa Fett
decides to have another go at mace
window This Time by leaving a sabotage
Mandalorian helmet in the wreckage of
the crashed endurance again his plan
fails but it isn't because of some
random Expendable Stormtrooper mace is
able to put two and two together seconds
before the device is set to go off so he
Force pulls Anakin away just far enough
to keep the blast from being lethal
thinking his plan has succeeded both
convinces Ora sing to return to the
crash site by telling her that Kuku will
pay a higher Bounty if they're able to
turn over the Jedi's head he also picks
a fight with another Bounty Hunter and
asserts himself as a guy who's been
taking all the risks if being an unruly
teenager sounds bad imagine being around
one with a homicidal streak they're
stopped by R2D2 who's able to repel the
Bounty Hunter's advances and the downed
venator and eventually returns with help
from
corant at this point Boba Fett knows
he's failed twice to kill the man
responsi for his father's murder and
it's starting to get to him oring
decides the best thing to do is to kill
one of the Clone hostages that been
saving for Kuku and send the footage to
the Jedi Council along with the demands
that M Wu face boba in response the Jedi
dispatch a couple of their own to track
down the bounty hunters and florum Boba
Aura and the rest of the crew are
confronted by plun and dooka Tano after
a quick Skirmish Boba does what he does
best and sets another bum off but the
blast only allows for Aura to escape so
she abandons the kid in order to to Safe
herself self realizing he's been
deserted by the only person he had left
in the universe Boba comes to understand
that maybe Vengeance isn't the best life
path he's arrested and although he
admits his wrongdoing he refuses to ever
forgive mace Wu by the time of the Clone
Wars season 4 episode deception Boba is
still serving his sentence it's a quick
oneandone moment but it gives us an
interesting glimpse into what bober has
been up to since his arrest after
Obi-Wan Kenobi takes on the identity of
a criminal named Reiko Hardin in order
to INF tra kuku's in a circle the Bounty
Hunter CAD Bane hires Boba to
interrogate the disguised Kenobi
understandably Obi-Wan keeps his
distance not wanting to hurt anyone
unnecessarily especially a young boy who
seems in over his head after a brief
fight Kenobi makes a get away leaving
Boba and his friend BOS in the dust
immediately after these events Boba Fett
heads up his own outfit of Outlaws
called crates claw when one of boba's
crew is killed in a seedi Tata bar by
former Sith assassin ass Ventress B
convinces her to join them in an
upcoming assignment you just killed one
of our team she and Boba immediately
butt heads as she thinks he's too young
and inexperienced to lead this band of
mercenaries it turns out Ventress is
sort of right over the course of their
assignment the other bounty hunters are
lost and the pair wind up fighting over
what to do with the actual Bounty by
this time Boba still has no idea how to
best someone with force abilities so
he's quickly overpowered left to spend
the following years wallowing in his
hatred Boba Fett begins his training
with cab Bane to become a better Bounty
Hunter eventually though the partnership
turned sour in an unproduced episode of
the Clone Wars Boba and Bane engaged in
a standoff that would have explained the
trademark dend in boba's helmet though
it never made it to where the battle
scene was nearly completed and would
have served as a basis for their
eventual rivalry seen at the end of the
book of Boba Fett and bnst to Boba he
has a female counterpart a young clone
of Dango far to dubbed Omega whose
genetic material is as pure fat DNA as
boba's own aided by by clone Force 99
Omega is kept safe from the newly formed
Galactic Empire looking to use her
whether Boba ever learned about his
sister remains a mystery not every job
goes as smoothly as Boba would like
while some bounties are quick and easy
others are a bit more complicated
occasionally damaging our favorite
mercenaries reputation one such job is
chronicled in the Marvel comic series
Star Wars Bounty Hunters which tells the
story of boba fets bod's corellian job
about 10 years before A New Hope hiring
Boba the air to the mner whale syndic
puts an assassination team together to
take out a Target on corellia before
things go south it all gets a bit sticky
when a member of the team named Nonono
lash takes out their employer which pits
the full Wrath of the mourner's whale
Syndicate against them hoping to kill
lash for her betrayal the Boba goes off
script putting him at odds with another
teammate the cyborg Byer Valance Who
just so happens to be lasher's Protege
because of this job boba's reputable
work ethic is singed and the Bounty
Hunter goes into hiding for a time it's
only after capturing fellow Bounty hun
Hunter cage Vander a year later as
detailed in the video game Star Wars
Jedi Survivor the Boba is ushered back
into the bounty hunting community's good
greaters this capture opened the door
for some other high-paying opportunities
including one that made him most famous
among Star Wars fans by the time the
Galactic Civil War officially commenced
Boba Fett was hired by the notorious
gangster Jabba the Hut on tatween back
on the desert planets the Bounty Hunter
makes waves around ma Eisley where he
frequently enforces the Hut's will on
his enemies before the Empire sets it
sights on two droids wandering around
the desert with hidden Death Star plans
Boba travels to corusant to take out a
handful of Rebel spies however because
he disintegrates them leaving no trace
of their bodies Darth Vader refuses to
pay drawing the events of A New Hope
Boba Fett acces Jabba's enforcer when
the gangster confronts Han Solo about
his enormous debt the short story added
muscle also reveals That Boba was
planning on leaving tne during this time
but after catching wind of the Empire's
hunt for R2D2 and C3PO he decides to
investigate game it's during this
endeavor That Boba tracks the droids
across the desert eventually concluding
that their time on the LGE moisture Farm
is what prompted the Empire to kill Luke
Skywalker's Uncle Owen and Aunt baru
additionally he also deduces that there
was a third member of the last household
who likely traveled with the droids but
they wouldn't meet until later at some
point drawing the rule of the Empire
Boba Fett finds himself on kajam a world
on the outer room where he's hired to
capture fellow Bounty Hunter zingo
gabner as chronicled in the Marvel comic
Star Wars age of rebellion Boba fet he
gets his prey which earns him the
respect of the press locals one man in
particular pleads with Boba for his help
and liberating their Village attempting
to appeal to the good inside instead the
Bounty Hunter turns on the do gooder
recognizing that the man is worth plenty
of credits himself not every Boba Fett
story ends with him as a villain he may
work for them often but sometimes the
goodness within him Peaks through in
darkh Horse comic Star Wars hyperspace
stories Issue 7 Boba reluctantly takes a
job for a young W named Vivi vavine is a
daughter of senator yua who worked
alongside Obi-Wan Kenobi Anakin
Skywalker and Padme amadala join the
Clone Wars though her father died saving
her life his memory lives on in the
small doll that had gifted her one she
needs boba's help to find sadly Boba
spends the entire issue saving theine
from other bounty hunters who want to
capture her for the Empire and thus her
doll is never actually found but
remembering how precious his father's
armor is to him Boba tells the young W
to never stop searching not long after
Luke Skywalker blows up the Death Star
the defeated and humiliated Darth Vader
hires Boba Fett and the W Bounty Hunter
black canten for some off the books jobs
he can't trust a stormtrooper with under
Vader th boba's new mission is to track
down the young rebel pilot who made that
impossible shot and bring him to the
dark lord I and to apprehend the
Millennium Falcon too knowing Han Solo's
usual haunt Boba quickly connects The
Smuggler with the crazy old wizard Ben
Kenobi while at the mo eely Cantina
there he captures a young moisture
farmer who builds of beans on Luke's
identity this takes him to Kenobi's
desert home just in time for Luke's
return hoping to find some of old Ben's
Jedi TCH to advance his own training
Luke is surprised by Boba Fett's arrival
blinded by one of boba's weapons Luke
fights valiantly against the experienced
Bounty Hunter and mistakes him for a
stormtrooper loose connection to the
force gives him an advantage and after a
seriously bloody battle the young
Skywalker gains the upper hand and
escapes with what he came for defeated
Boba reports Luke's identity to Darth
Vader who finally recognizes that he and
Padme had a son after all near the end
of the Galactic Empire Boba Fett becomes
one of the most sought after bounty
hunters in the galaxy in the Empire
Strikes Back Boba continues his mission
to track down the Millennium Falcon but
Vader wants to make sure his employee
doesn't fall back into his old habits
you are free to use any methods
necessary but I want them alive no
disintegrations naturally Vader didn't
just hire one Bounty Hunter for the job
he hired several including members of
boba's former outfit crates claw the
short story wait for it explains that
BOS and denar wanted to form an alliance
with Boba reliving old times but the
Mandalorian armor clad Hunter emphasizes
his need for the extra credits and opts
to work solo it turns out that this is
the right move as bober is able to
monitor solo and disc crew on their way
to best bin and he follows closely
behind enslave one warning Darth Vader
ahead of time Boba makes sure that the
Empire arrives to occupy Cloud City
before the Millennium Falcon lands the
perfect trap for The elusive Rebel
Smuggler turning the rebels over to
Darth Vader Boba makes a deal with the
Sith Lord that allows him to deliver Han
Solo personally to his other employer
Jabba the Hut this of course means
freezing Han Solo and Carbonite in front
of his friends thereby creating one of
the most stylish War pieces in the
Galaxy what if he doesn't survive he's
worth a lot to me the Empire will
compensate you if he dies put him in
after capturing Luke's friends and
freezing solo Vader gives Boba Fett
permission to leave with his Bounty his
job for the Empire is now complete aided
by a band of Storm Troopers Boba paraded
the Frozen solo through Cloud City but
he is soon pursued by the young
Skywalker and his friends unfortunately
for the rebels Boba Fett lows Han Solo
above slave one and blasts off into
space heading back towards tne to
collector's Bounty but before Boba could
make it to Jabba's Palace there was a
brief detour or three to make along the
way set between The Empire Strikes Back
and Return of the Jedi Marvel Star Wars
comics hosted a large scale crossover
event spanning throughout all of their
biggest titles called War of the bounty
hunters this conflict kicks off after
Boba first tracks down and battles Nano
lash the same Bounty Hunter who had
double crossed him years prior leaving
lash for dead Boba continues on to
deliver solo to jabber just one problem
the Carbonite Matrix that The Smuggler
is Frozen inside of proves unstable to
fix it Boba makes a pit stop onar Shada
and fights in a local Gladiator arena in
order to pay for the repairs on Solo's
prison competing under cover as bestar
braw ajango in honor of his father Boba
wins but fails to get the credits he was
after returning to solo he finds a
Smuggler Carbonite frozen body stolen
naturally Boba does what any good Bounty
Hunter would do he hunts down his prey
things only get worse though as Jabba
believes that Boba sold solo to another
buyer forcing the Huds to pay a high
price bounty on boba's head in reality
solo was stolen by the criminal
Syndicate Crimson Dawn specifically
under the orders of Solo's former lover
Kira her intentions aren't pure either
though Kira decides to sell solo at
auction thus putting boba in quite the
predicament while attempting to reclaim
Han Solo and restore his reputation Boba
is attacked by four L and zukus whom he
quickly dispatches learning about the
auction for solo Boba flies to jakara to
retrieve the Frozen Smuggler only to run
into Basque who attempts to appeal to
their long history ruthless as always
Boba leaves bosal in the cold as a
warning to those who might get in his
way upon infiltrating the auction Boba
devises a plan to steal back solo only
to be confronted by Princess Leia
Chewbacca and Lando kisian after a
tussle with Chewy Lando offers a bounty
hunter the chance to NAB solo for the
Rebellion but Bobo refuses noting that
his code won't let him suddenly switch
sides on a jab as Jabba the Hut wins the
auction Darth Vader arrives and claims
Han Solo as his own hoping to use a
Smuggler as bait for Luke once more
forcing an uneasy alliance with balance
who hates him for all but killing his
mentor Nano Boba intercepts solo from
the Imperial Fleet and reclaims his
Bounty it's not exactly a piece of cake
but his knowledge of Imperial systems
helps the operation go smoothly and
surprisingly Boba betrays Valance along
the way before finally delivering solo
to Jabba in person demanding full
payment for his Services Boba Fett's
days as a Star Wars Galaxy's Bounty
Hunter MVP are shortlived in Return of
the Jedi set possibly up to a year after
War of the bounty hunters the
Mandalorian clone seems at first to be
enjoying his victory over Han Solo
hanging out with Jabba in his Palace and
making sure things don't get too crazy
naturally things go arai when Luke
Skywalker fails a rescue and finds
himself sentenced to die in Jabba's
great pit of Caron before being fed to
Jabba's favorite sand monster the salac
pit Luke breaks free so Boba steps in to
try and thwart the Rebel's Escape call
it unlucky dumb or just plain outmatched
but in spite of boba's high-tech gear
this conflict doesn't go well for the
Bounty Hunter instead he winds up
falling into the sarlac Pit himself
after his jetpack is accidentally
damaged by a blinded Han Solo following
these events which also resulted in
Jabba's death at the hands of Princess
Leia it's genuinely thought that Boba
Fett died here on taten from here on
nobody hears much from the wbe
Mandalorian Bounty Hunter at least for a
number of years talk about an
anticlimactic ending except it isn't the
end to the Delight of Star Wars fans
everywhere Boba Fett just as he did in
the now non-conical Star Wars expanded
universe survives the salac even if it
takes him a while to break free in the
flashback scene in The Book of Boba Fett
Premiere the Bounty Hunter wakes up some
time after the events of Han Solo's
rescue and desperately Burns an enormous
hole into the creatur's Insight of
course he eventually claws his way out
of the beastly pit before passing out
face first in the sand from there boba
only awakens as jawwa strip him of his
armor leaving him for dead though Boba
would remain in the desert for a while
his father's Mandalorian armor would
eventually be claimed by T martial KB
vth who would use it to defend his
hometown of M pelo meanwhile B is found
by a band of Tuscan Raiders who claim
him as their prisoner alongside an
unnamed rodian turns out bobaa doesn't
always have the best luck after a failed
escape attempt Boba gains the respect of
the tribe after saving a young Tuscan
from a reptilian sand Beast that roams
the desert floor after it kills his
fellow captive Boba strangles the
creature before it can kill his child
captor thus earning himself a place
within the tribe upon being accepted
into the Tuscan Raider tribe Boba Fett
quickly adapts to their ways this
includes their culture their occupations
and their Weaponry most notably how to
properly wield a gaffy
[Music]
stick I am holding it the same from the
time he was tsen to the salac pit to the
time he began to thrive within the
Tuscan tribe nearly a year had passed
after being burned by so many wouldbe
families throughout his life this was
the first time Boba felt as if he truly
belonged somewhere it wasn't until the
pike Syndicate began to disrupt their
way of life including killing a number
of tuscans That Boba decided to take
matters into his own hands to protect
his new people after training some
Tuscan Warriors how to ride on speeder
bikes booba leaves an assault on a cargo
train carrying spice though the Pikes
fight back they're no match for Boba
Fett and his Newfound tribe who soon
overpower them vowing that the pike
Syndicate must pay a toll to the tuscans
to continue their operations the tribe
celebrates as a gift for his efforts the
Tuscan Chief presents Boba with a small
lizard that initiates a very psychedelic
Vision Quest in his vision Boba sees his
childhood on Cino and his time in the
salac pit which reminds him of the life
he once lived as well as his father's
Legacy inspired by his vision Boba Fett
decides to return to Mosa Le to ensure
that the pike Syndicate treats the
tuscans well the Pikes don't exactly
refuse but they don't pay Boba either
since they're already paying protection
money to a rival gang the kentan
Striders have already collected
protection money for the same territory
you lay claim to Boba vows to handle it
but Upon returning to his tribe's Camp
he finds them dead including the chief
and the young Tusan he befriended
unbeknownst to Boba the pike syndic
cured the more killed during his absence
framing the kintan Striders gang for the
massacre heartbroken Boba burns the
bodies on a p takes a banther and heads
off into the desert it's drawing his
grief that he finds a wounded fenic
Shand and returns her to MOS Eisley
paying for the cybernetic body
modifications that save her life owing
him a dead Shand agrees to help Boba
retrieve his ship from Jabba's Palace
then the two of them take out all the
fed's enemies they start with a kintan
strid whom Boba still believes
responsible for the tusken deaths and
they destroyed a sarac pits not long
after Boba sure knows how to enact his
revenge bober had hoped to find his
armor at the pit but he was quickly
disappointed thankfully he discovers
that KOB fanth who had worn his armor
for a time had given it to a
Mandalorian as it turns out this
Mandalorian was none other than well the
Mandalorian the helmeted hero from the
show of the same name djarin was once a
foundling but he now belongs to a
certain set of the mandalorians who hold
tightly to the ancient Creed tracking
jarin to tython Boba and Shand threaten
the life of jarn's own foundling the
young four sensitive grou which puts
sebesar plated Mandalorian on guard bber
demands his armor back but jarin only
agrees to talk when shant whom had
encountered previously puts her weapon
down before long the two bounty hunters
come to an agreement boobo reclaims his
armor but now he wears his tusken Garb
underneath in exchange for the armor
jarin ASA Bobo and Shand helping protect
grou from the Imperial forces led by mof
Gideon who wishes to used his child's
force abilities for nefarious purposes
ever since Boba Fett lived among the
Tuscan people he has rediscovered the
concepts of honor and respect it's
because of this that he accepts his new
Mission now standing against the empire
he once contracted for tragically it's
not enough despite the Trio's best
efforts grou is taken by a band of dark
Troopers who destroy jarn's ship the
razor Crest and flee the scene
thankfully Boba still has a ship so he
uses it to get the three of them offw
and on the move to rescue the potential
Jedi recruit
allying themselves with New Republic
martial kadun and the mercenary mix
mayfeld the team comes up with a plan to
retrieve the child but before they can
follow through with it they need to
figure out where he actually is they
soon find themselves at an imperial
Refinery on morac where jarin and
Mayfield must pretend to be Imperial
Troopers it's especially difficult for
jarin who is forced to remove his helmet
in opposition to his Mandalorian Creed
after attaining Gru's location Boba Fett
intercepts Gideon's Cruiser while his
allies including new Mandalorian cruits
bat tanre and CoStar Reeves infiltrate
the ship to rescue their little green
friend the plan ultimately proved
successful especially with the help of
Jedi Knight Luke Skywalker who arrives
Just in Time chapter 16 the rescue ends
of jarin and grou reunited thanks to no
small B to Boba Fett's assistant
immediately following his job with
djarin Boba Fett returns to taten kills
bib Fortuna and takes a seat on Jabba's
Throne ready to take over the Empire
Boba faces the first Challengers to his
new found position the hudz twins as the
self-proclaimed dimeo of mos esper Boba
vows to rule not with fear as Jabba had
but with honor and respect as he learned
from the tuscans after a few weeks news
has spread That Boba Fett is in fact
alive and well and his enemies aren't
happy to hear it the Hut twins cousins
of De old jabber don't take this change
terribly well using the wiie black
canten to try to interrogate and later
assassinate Boba the twins attempt to
overpower the Mandalorian armor wearing
Dao to no avail not wanting to start a
war over a worthless Rock the twins
leave taten offering up a new Rancor as
a gift for boba's Palace and releasing
cantan from his contract impressed with
the wook resolve Boba hes as would be
assassin as an enforcer alongside the
gang of cyborgs had previously
conscripted now the leader of an
impressive Force Boba Fett challenges
the bike syndicates Authority and
attempts to convince most Esper's other
crime Lords to fight alongside him but
they refuse recognizing Their Fear of
the Pikes Boba convinces them to at
least remain neutral as he deals with
the liberation of the city for seeing a
Turf War Shan convinces djarin to Aid in
their conflict it isn't long before the
Pikes get wind of Boba Fett's plan and
hire an enforcer to make sure that he's
cut off from any additional resources
their choice CAD Bane boba's former
mentor and the most notable bounty
hunter from the Clone Wars era Boba Fett
is a coldblooded killer who worked for
the Empire after djarin convinces
Marshall koban of free town to help Boba
take on the Pikes Bane arrives and
demands that none of the people of free
toown assist his adversary in any way
then he takes out vanth and his Deputy
from there Bane travels to MOS esper
where he reveals to boa that the Pikes
were the ones who killed his Tuscan
tribe in race Boba nearly attacks his
former Mentor but he manages to stop
himself with an impressive amount of
restraint sadly his new found honor
isn't enough to gain the upper hand
moser's other criminal forces
unsurprisingly betray him and boba's
forces are nearly depleted thankfully
the people of freet toown come anyway as
does grou and boba's faction soon
overpower was the Pikes this all leads
to a final confrontation between Boba
and Bane that mirrors their previously
and finished door from the Clone Wars
Boba uses his new tusken training to
disarm and dispatch Bane leaving him
seemingly dead in the street following
the turf war Boba Fett Reigns Supreme
Over Mo esper as fenic Shand
assassinates the heads of the pike
Syndicate despite all the violence and
bloodshed is a relatively happy ending
for the fan
[Music]
favorite